vamos a usar este ejemplo para tratar de
comprender los tres tipos de estado de
cuenta de ingresos y con suerte al
comprender estos estados de cuenta
podremos comprender el ejemplo y para
comenzar vamos a enfocarnos en el
segundo mes aquí lo que hicimos es
reescribir estos estados de cuenta de
ingresos con base devengada de manera
que parezca un estado de cuenta el
estado de cuenta de ingresos del segundo
mes que damos que tiene 400 dólares de
entradas se tuvieron 200 dólares de
gastos con un ingreso final de 200
dólares el estado de cuenta de ingresos
nos dice lo que ha sucedido en un
período de tiempo cuál fue la actividad
cuáles fueron las entradas cuáles fueron
los gastos este es un ejemplo muy muy
simplificada pues no muestra impuestos
no muestra intereses no muestra otro
tipo de gastos también aquí escriben la
hoja de balance al final del primer mes
y la hoja de balance al final del
segundo mes también pueden ver esto como
la hoja de balance al inicio del segundo
mes el estado de cuenta de ingresos les
dice qué es lo que pasó durante un
periodo de tiempo mientras que lass
de balance son imágenes instantáneas en
un momento muy preciso es lo que nos
dice en esencia es que es lo que tenían
los activos o bienes las cosas que me
pueden dar un beneficio futuro y los
pasivos indican cosas a las que yo les
tengo que dar beneficios futuros o cosas
que yo debo eso es lo que tengo esto es
lo que debo y eso es el capital o
patrimonio neto que me queda debe quitar
los pasivos a los activos así que al
comienzo del segundo mes y a finales del
primer mes tengo 100 dólares en efectivo
no tengo cuentas por cobrar no le debo
nada a nadie a 100 dólares le quito 20
dólares y me quedan 100 dólares como
patrimonio neto que es lo que los dueños
de la compañía pueden decir que tienen
como patrimonio neto al inicio del mes
si nos adelantamos y vemos el final del
segundo mes ahora yo la debo al banco
100 dólares por eso es un menos 100
normalmente no se toma en cuenta si en
una hoja de balance de alguna compañía
pero bueno vamos a simplificar esto aquí
tengo una cuenta por cobrar
400 dólares por lo que mis activos son
de 300 dólares las cuentas por cobrar
son activos porque alguien me debe a mí
esta cantidad aún no tengo pasivos por
la que restamos todos los los pasivos a
nuestros activos y tenemos un patrimonio
neto de 300 dólares aquí podemos ver
entonces que el patrimonio neto al
inicio del segundo mes es de 100 dólares
y a finales de este segundo mes es de
300 dólares y para pasar de este punto a
este otro punto de 100 a 300 mi
patrimonio neto debió aumentar 200
dólares en este periodo de tiempo y este
aumento debió de llegar de algún lugar y
es ahí donde nuestro estado de cuenta de
ingresos toma lugar describe cuál es el
cambio en nuestro patrimonio neto dentro
de un periodo de tiempo y ahí se van a
mostrar los 200 dólares de ingresos que
aparecen de diferencia entre el inicio
del mes y el final del mes y aquí hay
algo que podría confundirlos en este
momento pues como reconciliamos todo
esto con el efectivo sabemos que durante
este periodo obtuvimos un ingreso de 200
dólares
base devengada pero si vemos el efectivo
pasamos de 100 dólares a menos 100
dólares pareciera que hubiéramos perdido
200 dólares como es que podemos
reconciliar esto de que obtuvimos un
ingreso de 200 dólares con el hecho de
que en efectivo perdimos 200 dólares esa
reconciliación se va a dar en el estado
de cuenta de efectivo que veremos más
adelante